this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream sign
up today and get access to my new
logistics of d-day series on nebula over
the last decade Elon Musk has become one
of the most famous men on the planet
revolutionizing the banking automotive
rocket and energy industries in a
relatively short period of time his
reputation for disrupting established
industries has elevated his status to
some sort of tech Jesus for money and
with his latest venture neuro-link musk
appears to be trying to take that status
to the next level near link is to me
Musk's most fascinating venture yet with
the goal of developing technologies to
unearth the mysteries of our most vital
organ the brain we've decoded our DNA
and even discovered methods to
selectively edit it we've invented tiny
devices that can be implanted into the
body to correct our heartbeat we can
take organs from donors and transfer
them to those in need
we can perform total joint replacements
and artificially grow skin from stem
cells but the brain remains a mystery in
many ways with little to no options for
intervention when malfunctions occur
we've only scratched the surface of this
organs operation and to me it's one of
the final great frontiers of science if
you pay attention to just the headlines
of mainstream science publications this
technology will seem like muskers trying
to create cyborg humans we're perfectly
healthy people will voluntarily get
biomedical implants to augment their
brain function but that's just musk
using his tech Jesus status to generate
hype for his latest business venture in
reality neural Inc is something much
more meaningful but perhaps less
exciting for the average person this
technology could help accelerate our
exploration of the brain and help people
with severe brain malfunctions to live
happier and longer lives but to
understand what neural Inc is trying to
do we must first look at technology's
neural link is looking to improve on and
get a basic understanding of how the
nervous system works for that I will
pass you over to Stephanie from our new
channel real science we have many
different kinds of receptors in our body
to gather information about the world
around us take the hair cells of your
inner ear
activated when vibrated by sound and the
cochlea the snail shaped organ in your
inner ear is shaped in a way to allow
different portions of it to be activated
by different frequencies thanks to the
differing stiffness of the basilar
membrane along the length of the cochlea
this means the base of the cochlea
closest to the oval window connected to
the outer ear is sensitive to high
frequencies up to 20,000 Hertz and as we
descend deeper into the snail shaped
sensory organ lower frequencies begin to
vibrate the hair cells until we reach
the apex of the cochlea where
frequencies as low as 20 Hertz can be
detected when activated these hair cells
send electrical impulses through the
auditory nerve to your brain for
interpretation the exact process of
interpretation is insanely complicated
and beyond the knowledge of man as there
are thousands of neurons involved that
gradually branch out as they travel to
their final destination but thanks to
our understanding of the signal input
stage we can actually just bypass the
ear as a sensory organ altogether and
artificially stimulate the nervous
system to allow the Deaf to hear this is
exactly what cochlear implants do seeing
videos like this is quite possibly the
most heartwarming thing on the Internet
children who have never heard the sound
of their mother's voice suddenly able to
hear for the first time their smiles
would make anyone see the value in this
technology so how does it work the
device consists of a microphone and a
sound processor which in turn generates
electrical signals to send to an
electrode array which is actually
inserted directly into the cochlea where
it can directly stimulate the nurse of
the inner ear with electrical impulses
this bypasses both the hair cells of the
inner ear and the sound transmitting
structures of the outer ear and so it
can help people who have malfunctions in
these parts of the ear an astounding
technology but it does not require any
implantation of medical devices into the
brain as neuro-link plans to do it
simply activates the nervous system at
its input stage creating a technology
which could say activate the auditory
cortex directly to allow us to hear is a
whole other ballgame current technology
on this side of things is highly
invasive take the Utah array this
implantable device consists of about 256
electrodes which can both read and
stimulate neural activity this is
exactly the function neural link is
working to improve on this lady is doing
something amazing this medical implant
was placed on the surface of her brain
at the motor cortex where it records the
activity of the neurons in that area the
data from those neurons were then used
to effect a mouse cursor which allowed
her to type and use a computer despite
having no movement in her arms the
researchers took this a step further and
began using the neural recordings to
allow another woman to control the
movement of a robotic arm this is the
exact technology neural Inc is seeking
to improve upon and there is a lot to be
improved upon the first issue with the
Utah array is the material properties of
the electrodes these electrodes are like
stiff and sharp needles which allows
them to penetrate into the brain and
record the internal activity but this
causes problems with the body's immune
response this is the first part of neuro
links plans to improve this technology
by making these electrodes much smaller
and flexible the Utah arrays electrodes
vary from about 0.03 millimeters at
their tip to about 0.1 at their base
near link threads are much smaller at
about zero point zero zero four to zero
point zero zero six millimeters
side-by-side that looks something like
this making the threads thinner allows
them to affect a smaller portion of the
brain making them less likely to affect
nerve function or to puncture blood
vessels but perhaps more critically
makes the threads more flexible allowing
them to move with the brain as it
jiggles around in the skull this is
actually a huge problem the tissue of
the brain is very soft and elastic if
you have stiff needle-like electrodes
fixed in place the brain will simply
deform around them this causes
inflammation and scar tissue to form
around the needle which over time will
block the needles ability to read brain
activity through the scar tissue
matching the electrodes material
properties to the brains as close as
possible will allow the electrode to
move and deform with the brain and thus
decrease the scar tissue formation and
extend the life of the electrodes a
vital design parameter with medical
implants so neural link has moved away
from these stiff silicon electrodes and
created thinner flexible gold electrodes
coated in a conductive biocompatible
thin film polymer but electrodes like
this come with their own issues their
small size and flexibility makes them
very difficult for even the skilled hand
of a surgeon to insert so neural link
has also developed a robotic electrode
inserter
to lend a helping hand the robot comes
with a suite of camera and light modules
to allow the robot to accurately insert
the threads the robot uses a needle to
advance the electrode thread to the
desired depth in the brain before
retracting and leaving the thread behind
this robot on average could insert an
electrode thread in a little over a
minute even when the surgeon performed
manual adjustments to avoid blood
vessels near links white paper put
particular emphasis on this ability as
the breaking of the blood-brain barrier
is suspected to be a key driver in the
brain inflammatory response which again
can cause scarring and reduce the
electrodes function it's important to
note that neural ink isn't the first
company to create thin film polymer
electrodes but with this robot and their
work on streamlining the manufacturing
process for mass production has put near
a link in a strong position to create a
viable medical device for sale
they have also increased the channel
count significantly the Utah electrode
array can reach a max of 256 channels
whereas this prototype system which
nearer link surgically implanted any rat
and successfully recorded from has 96
electrode threads each containing 32
electrodes for a total of three thousand
and seventy two channels to read from
this is a very important design
parameter as more data equals more
control this journal paper titled
learning to control a brain machine
interface for reaching and grasping by
primates details an experiment where
researchers implanted a brain machine
interface into the brain of macaque
monkeys they trained the monkeys to
complete a task on a screen using a
small handheld controller they recorded
the monkeys
cortex neural activity during this
training and mocked a robot arm too much
it's hand movements they confirmed that
the more neurons they could record from
the higher the probability of the
robotic arm matching the monkeys actual
arm movements note this footage is from
a later 2008 study where the researchers
actually trained the monkeys to feed
themselves using the robotic arm so if
we can record from more channels we can
expect to achieve higher accuracy and
later as the technology progresses we
can perform more complicated tasks
perhaps instead of controlling a cursor
or a robot arm we can fit exoskeletons
to paralyzed patients to allow them to
walk however we've one last and
significant technological challenge
before that can ever be considered we
somehow need to get this data out of the
brain the electrodes record analog data
from the brain which needs to be
amplified as the neural signals are very
faint with voltages as low as 10 micro
volts noise then needs to be filtered
out and finally the analog signal is
converted to binary data this reduction
to simple bits is vital as we somehow
need to transfer this data to a computer
outside of the head installing a
processing board inside the brain is
simply not an option looking at the Utah
array we can see that there is a lot
left to be desired the electrodes
themselves require a connector which
bears an uncanny resemblance to the head
Jack from the matrix when the
researchers wanted to use the brain
machine interface they had to plug these
massive niro port blocks to the
connector which fed the data to a huge
amplifier and signal processor neural
link is trying to fit the amplification
and data filtering step inside the
onboard processors this is their
prototype board which they fitted into
the rat here the electrode threads fed
into twelve custom-built microchips each
capable of processing 256 channels of
data equaling the 3072 channels coming
from the threads
however this prototype system simply
used a USBC port for both power and data
transfer which again is going to require
an ugly port breaking the skin this
isn't just a cosmetic issue it's a
massive open wound in the body's first
line of defense foreign fetch
Annagh leads straight to the body's most
valuable organ it's simply not an option
for a commercial product so neural links
next technological challenge is to
develop a method to both power and
transfer data to these implantable
devices elan made some offhanded
comments about this during his
presentation and then the the interface
to the to the to the chip is wireless so
you have no wires poking out of your
head
very very important so you it's it's
basically bluetooth to your phone
because we'll have to watch the App
Store updates for that one make sure we
don't have a driver issue updating good
one Elon ok so beyond joking about
people's brain implants potentially
having driver issues this comet in
typical Elon fashion is a little
misleading Bluetooth doesn't actually
have the bandwidth needed to transfer
this much data so an alternative method
will be needed to transfer it from the
device to outside the skin the
neuro-link white paper does not shed
much light on the specific part of their
plants but they did present very briefly
in their presentation that their first
plant product consists of four of their
n1 chips three will be implanted in the
motor cortex for control and one will be
implanted in the somatosensory cortex
for sensor feedback these will feed data
to an inductive charging and data
transfer coil under the skin behind the
ear which will then transfer the data to
a wearable computer and charger worn
behind the ear this device will probably
perform some further data processing
before transferring the simplified data
through bluetooth to a phone where will
allow the user to control a cursor on
the phone or a computer near a link
stated an ambitious goal of beginning
human trials this year in order to begin
the long a difficult task of receiving
FDA approval if they manage to get the
Food and Drug Administration approval
for a commercial product this would be a
major leap forward for the treatment of
injuries resulting in paralysis
potentially transforming the life of the
hundreds of thousands of people living
with paralysis allowing them to complete
simple tasks like controlling their
computers without the help
Beaucaire while I don't see healthy
people using these kinds of devices any
time soon as implanting any device into
the body
never mind the brain will always be a
massive risk it's certainly a plausible
scenario that future humans could elect
to have a device like this implanted
there is a legitimate worry that machine
learning and artificial intelligence is
going to pose an existential threat to
human society in the near future and you
can learn more about it by watching the
AI race on curiosity stream curiosity
stream has thousands of documentaries
from some of the world's best
documentary makers and for just $2.99 a
month you'll get access to our new
streaming service Nebula Nebula is a
streaming service made by creators for
creators curiosity stream has been a
massive supporter of this channel and
has they even funded our new channel
real science as well as their new
logistics of d-day series which is an
exclusive original series for nebula so
far I have covered the reasons for
choosing Normandy as a landing location
and the deception tactics the LS used to
stop the Germans from discovering their
plants next I will be exploring how the
Allies managed to punch a hole in the
wall of fortress Europe to allow the
thousands of ships planes and men of the
invasion force to stream through in a
single day with nebula original series
like this ad free videos downloadable
episodes and iOS with an Android app on
the way and no algorithm presenting you
with endless clickbait distractions
nebula is the best way to watch your
favorite educational youtubers like
window for productions polly mater
lessons from the screenplay
Lindsay Alice Kent obento and he will
get it all for free by signing up to
curiosity stream as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
you